Traduttore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Revisore: SILVIA ALLONE
Da poco meno di un mese
sono cominciate le scuole.
Voi ve lo ricordate uno
dei vostri primi giorni di scuola?
Quando si rincontrano gli amici,
ci si racconta di come
sono state le vacanze,
delle belle giornate, no?
Eppure sono sicuro che ognuno di noi,
indipendentemente
che la generazione sia la mia,
che sia la vostra o quella
dei vostri figli, se li avete,
ognuno di noi, almeno una volta,
ha pensato a questo.
[Che palle, si ritorna a scuola]
(Risate)
E in fondo chi ci può dar torto:
tre mesi di assoluta libertà,
però con lo spauracchio, con il fantasma
di settembre che ritorna,
con la scuola che ritorna
e quando ritorna giù compiti,
verifiche, studio.
Che palle.
E allora perché esiste la scuola?
È un obbligo.
Questo non significa
che dobbiamo abolire la scuola,
ci mancherebbe altro,
però perché esiste veramente la scuola?
Normalmente le risposte che diamo
potrebbero essere queste:
per educare i giovani
a stare nella società,
per crescerli come lavoratori,
per crescerli come persone.
Quante volte glielo abbiamo detto questo,
ai ragazzi e ai giovani?
Un milione, forse un miliardo.
Ma loro ci credono?
Vi faccio un esempio:
quante volte ci siamo
trovati, tutti quanti,
di fronte a quel mattone di storia,
di filosofia, di letteratura
a dannare la vita e pensare:
"Quando mai mi servirà?"
Ecco, allora che cosa facevamo?
Cercavamo magari una distrazione,
guardavamo la tv,
o quando eravamo più piccoli
magari andavamo a giocare con gli amici;
o, quando eravamo più grandicelli,
chiudevamo il libro,
ci vestivamo e magari uscivamo.
Ecco, la fatica che noi facevamo
nel chiudere il libro, nel vestirsi,
nell'uscire con gli amici,
i giovani di oggi l'hanno minimizzata
in un solo movimento.
Ecco, questo non è solo
il simbolo moderno della socialità.
Non voglio parlare di questo oggi.
Questo strumento è in grado
di reperire qualsiasi informazione
dello scibile umano,
semplicemente facendo
una ricerca su Google.
Ma più che altro è in grado di riprodurre
qualcosa che i libri
non saranno mai in grado di fare.
Sono immagini in movimento: i video.
Per cui, in realtà,
la prima causa di distrazione dei giovani,
al giorno d'oggi, grazie a questo,
è YouTube.
YouTube conta circa 2 miliardi
di utenti attivi ogni mese,
in rapida ascesa.
Più di un miliardo di ore
di video visti al giorno.
Sono tante.
In un'era dove l'informazione
è diventata la moneta principale
e dove l'accesso veloce alle informazioni
è diventato una priorità,
con la scusa di dare ai giovani
uno strumento in grado
di reperire informazioni,
di fatto, noi gli abbiamo dato
la prima causa di distrazione.
Eppure, l'obbligo di studiare
esiste ancora.
Eppure siamo ancora lì,
di fronte a quel libro,
a quel tomo di storia,
di letteratura, di geologia,
a dannare la vita intera,
a dannare i professori
perché mi fanno studiare una cosa
che probabilmente la troverai
tranquillamente su Internet,
quando mi serve,
se mai mi servirà.
E allora ecco che torna
il tema del "A cosa mi serve".
Oggi viviamo - in realtà, non oggi,
negli ultimi anni ormai -
in un clima di scarso lavoro,
soprattutto a livello giovanile.
Lo leggiamo tutti i giorni sui giornali,
lo ascoltiamo alla radio
e in più serpeggia tra i giovani
quella sensazione che,
per ottenere un lavoro decente,
oggi forse non ti serve studiare.
Ti bastano due cose: fortuna
e le giuste raccomandazioni.
Che studiare, allora,
magari non ti serve,
anzi che ti basterebbe imparare
quelle quattro cose che ti servono
per rimediare un lavoro decente,
magari non ambizioso,
ma che ti porti a casa il pane
e il resto lo puoi trovare
tranquillamente su Internet.
Stiamo vivendo in un periodo
di fortissima disillusione
nei confronti dello studio
da entrambi i lati.
Il lato dei giovani, che vede nella scuola
un sistema antico, vecchio,
sorpassato, preistorico,
che non ti prepara alla "vita vera";
ma anche dal lato degli adulti,
dei genitori che vedono
sempre con più preoccupazione
il fatto di voler trovare un lavoro,
anche, di nuovo, non ambizioso,
ai propri figli.
Ecco quindi che crollano
le iscrizioni all'università,
ecco che si alza il tasso
di abbandono scolastico.
E non solamente per i ragazzi
anche in giovane età,
anche [per] i bambini ci preoccupiamo
di voler dare loro un lavoro
che già gli insegniamo
i lavori del futuro.
Ecco che i bambini cominciano a imparare
il cinese o la programmazione,
a discapito di materie come la geografia,
che sta lentamente
scomparendo dalle scuole.
E quindi, mi sembra che l'unico motivo
per il quale esiste
al giorno d'oggi la scuola
sia solo questo:
noi stiamo crescendo dei lavoratori,
prima che delle persone,
e a crescerli come persone
e a dargli una cultura
ci sta pensando Internet
con i suoi video, con i suoi hashtag,
ma anche con le sue notizie false.
E quindi, il tema che mi piacerebbe
che ci portassimo a casa tutti quanti,
e che magari ne discutessimo
con i nostri figli, con i giovani,
è come possiamo cambiare l'insegnamento,
per fare in modo che i giovani
si possano riallacciare alla cultura?
Già in realtà sbagliamo
perché noi non dobbiamo cambiare
le materie che consideriamo vecchie.
Di nuovo, la geografia, la letteratura,
il latino o la chimica vanno bene così.
Vi faccio un esempio: oggi -
soprattutto negli ultimi tempi,
l'avrete sentito -
viviamo in un clima di odio,
di divisione sociale, di suprematismo.
Se noi non studiassimo la storia,
ve lo ricordate l'ultima volta
cosa è successo,
dopo un clima di odio
o di divisione sociale e di suprematismo?
No, le materie vecchie vanno bene così.
Noi dobbiamo adeguare l'insegnamento
per fare in modo che i giovani
possano ritornare alla cultura.
E lo dobbiamo fare, in realtà,
con quello che ci ha contraddistinto
negli ultimi 20 anni,
e che ha contraddistinto
la crescita dei giovani,
che è la tecnologia digitale.
Oggi vorrei portarvi
una testimonianza, una visione
che abbiamo avuto
nella scuola dove lavoro,
di quello che potrebbe essere
una lezione nel futuro.
Lo abbiamo chiamato HOLODECK,
come il Ponte degli ologrammi.
Avete presente l'Enterprise?
L'astronave di Star Trek?
Qualcuno probabilmente
l'ha visto, Star Trek!
Ok, su quel ponte degli ologrammi
ci si poteva entrare e cambiava,
a seconda di quello che si voleva:
si poteva essere alle Maldive,
su un altro pianeta,
quello che si voleva.
Ecco, Holodeck per noi
è una classe in realtà virtuale,
dove ogni studente ha il proprio visore
ed è in grado di assistere
a delle lezioni di materie normali
come l'astronomia,
come la chimica, le scienze,
ma anche la storia e la geografia,
aumentate attraverso l'animazione 3D.
Oltretutto i ragazzi possono vedersi
all'interno dello spazio virtuale
e possono vedere le loro mani,
quindi possono interagire
con gli oggetti 3D.
Ecco che quindi
noi non stiamo andando a cambiare
cosa dobbiamo raccontare ai giovani,
stiamo aggiornando il
come lo vogliamo raccontare.
In realtà, utilizziamo una tecnologia
che è molto più sulle loro corde.
Un sistema di insegnamento
che è basato su quello
che loro normalmente vedono ogni giorno,
che sono le immagini in movimento.
Oggi avevamo pensato di portare una demo,
portarvi una demo di Holodeck,
grazie alle tecnologie di questa sala.
Sarebbe stato l'effetto Wow
di questo speech.
Purtroppo qualche giorno fa
la direzione dell'M9 ci ha detto
che questa sala
non sarebbe più stata in grado
di supportare
questo tipo di demo.
Per cui, io innanzitutto vi faccio
le mie più profonde scuse
e vi chiedo di fidarvi semplicemente
delle immagini che avete visto,
e della mia parola
sul fatto che questa tecnologia
è veramente incredibile.
Invitarvi, qualora lo vogliate,
a venirla a provare
direttamente a Big Rock,
lì almeno i visori funzionano.
(Risate)
Holodeck è una sperimentazione ancora,
non abbiamo la pretesa o la presunzione
che diventi la scuola del futuro,
ci piacerebbe però poterla integrare
a quello che è un sistema
di lezioni che esiste già,
come un laboratorio,
come un laboratorio di arte
o laboratorio di scienze
che già esistono nelle scuole.
Immaginatevi un'ora di astronomia,
un'ora di geografia,
un'ora di storia o un'ora di chimica
passata - un'ora alla settimana -
passata all'interno di Holodeck.
Sarebbe incredibile.
Anche perché è scientificamente provato
che quando uno studente ha a che fare
con una lezione di tipo interattivo,
quindi può interagire anche con le mani,
le sinapsi del cervello
si attivano molto di più.
Quindi una lezione
di tipo interattivo, in questo modo,
è molto, molto più efficace.
Noi dobbiamo ricominciare,
o meglio dobbiamo cominciare,
a usare la tecnologia
per riportare gli studenti
a innamorarsi di nuovo della cultura
e dobbiamo insegnare a utilizzare
le tecnologie che loro già hanno.
YouTube, che sembrava denigrassimo prima,
in mezzo a tanta porcheria
ha un sacco di video bellissimi
ed estremamente istruttivi,
i TED per primi.
(Risate)
La programmazione va bene
insegnarla ai bambini,
ma che abbia uno scopo,
che insegni loro come ragiona
logicamente un computer,
per fare in modo che loro possano imparare
a ragionare a livello critico,
a livello logico.
Ma soprattutto dobbiamo cercare
di reinsegnare a sognare ai nostri figli,
a sognare le persone che vorrebbero
essere da grandi
e lo dobbiamo fare appunto
con la tecnologia.
Dobbiamo farli innamorare della cultura,
perché solo la cultura
li farà crescere come persone.
Un recente studio di LEGO,
su un campione di circa 3.000 bambini,
ha riportato che alla domanda
"Cosa vorresti fare da grande?"
più di un terzo di loro ha detto
che vorrebbe fare lo youtuber,
invece che l'astronauta.
Questa cosa è agghiacciante.
In un momento come questo,
dove stiamo per affrontare
uno dei cambiamenti climatici
più catastrofici della nostra storia,
noi non abbiamo bisogno di youtuber,
noi abbiamo bisogno di scienziati.
Abbiamo bisogno di medici,
abbiamo bisogno di architetti,
abbiamo bisogno di politici giusti.
Abbiamo bisogno di tutti quegli eroi
che grazie alla loro cultura,
e al loro sapere,
possono rimediare agli errori del passato
e cercare di fare qualcosa
per curare questo pianeta.
O se non ce la possono fare,
trovare una soluzione per abbandonarlo.
Per cui sì, abbiamo bisogno di astronauti.
Io mi auguro che al prossimo
primo giorno di scuola
possiamo ricordare tutti quanti
ai nostri giovani, ai nostri figli,
il perché stanno andando a scuola,
il perché studiano.
Ricordiamogli di sognare,
di sognare un futuro migliore
o essere ispirati da altri sognatori.
E studiare tanto, e farsi una cultura,
e poter effettivamente
realizzare quei sogni.
Essere nel mezzo tra queste due cose,
in questo momento,
non ne vale veramente la pena.
Grazie.
(Applausi)